hallo zusammen ich möchte euch heute
zeigen dass unser adventskalender seit
heute online anbieter auf und ich frage
mich dann aber kurz ich zeige aber keine
inhalte damit ich keine spannung
vorwegnehme wer uns aber wirklich viele
gedanken auch über den adventskalender
gemacht und haben ja einen koffer
gestaltet damit eben auch müll vermieden
werden kann das heißt alles was drin ist
ist wirklich so dass komplett null
reduziert ist bzw komplett wegfällt ich
zeige euch das auch gleich falls sie den
adventskalender verschenken gold gibt es
auch hier aus in einen umschlag mit
einer karte die er beschriften kann dann
können ja nicht eintragen für wen und
von wem um noch eine kleine botschaft
reinschreiben finde ich ganz hübsch weil
ich mir dachte die meisten werden sich
den ball selbst können aber vielleicht
gibt ja auch einige wenige die den
verschenken wollen dann habt ihr hier
auf jeden fall den umschlag und müssten
eben nicht vorher auspacken sondern
könnte es hier außen machen also drumrum
ist eine banderole die kamera
tatsächlich auf einfach wegnehmen also
selbst wenn ihr dann sagt der rückschlag
da soll damit rein könnte einfach die
banderole runterziehen später wieder
drauf ziehen das paar wochen so ein paar
informationen mit drauf wir haben ja
einen koffer gestaltet der wirklich sehr
schön ist und den ihr später einfach
weiter verwenden könnt denn das ganze
bietet viel platz und wenn ihr den
koffer später leer habt könnt ihr den
benutzten um im kinderzimmer aufzuräumen
im kleiderschrank ordnung zu bewahren
ihr könnt daraus aber auch zum beispiel
einen koffer machen und zur hochzeit
verschränkungen flitterwochen baby
geschenk geburtstagsparty also ich
glaube da gibt es ganz viele ideen und
ich werde euch da auch auf pinto ist und
auf meinen social media kanälen einfach
ganz viele ideen zeigen dann habt ihr
hier drin eine karte und zwar eine
kleine anrede mit dabei ein persönlicher
gruß von mir da könnt ihr das gerne
durchlesen und hier seht ihr 26 kleine
geschenkkarton wir haben gedacht 24 war
langweilig machen 26 noch mal zusätzlich
und die sind alle unterschiedlich groß
alles ist quasi einen eigenen karton den
ihr dann entnehmen könnt und zustellen
zu können was da drin und diese karton
das sind der 26 einzelne die könnt ihr
später auch einfach weiter benutzen und
weiterführt oder sagen wir machen
nächstes jahr einen eigenen
adventskalender draußen parkt selber
geschenke rein und da war mir einfach
auch wichtig dass der karton so
gestaltet ist dass man sehen zu
weihnachten aber eben auch zu anderen
jahreszeiten verschenken kann denn hier
oben sind zwar die ziffern drauf damit
ihr wisst welche tür an welchem tag
geöffnet bergdolt aber wenn ihr sagt ihr
wollt die ziffern überkleben dann gibt
es hier noch dicker die wir schon
vorgefertigt haben einfach ein paar
sticker bögen untersteht auch drauf
welche tür mit welchem etikett damit man
es eben komplett übergeben kann oder ihr
könnt auszulassen um zum beispiel auch
mit dem film spielen da kann ja auch
sagen du bist meine nummer eins dann
kriegt man den karton nummer eins oder
irgendwie zum achtzehnten geburtstag
ihres reinpacken also da haben wir
wirklich ganz viele ideen wir werden
euch sagt glaube ich auch echt zu
kommandieren mit tollen ideen zum
basteln und weiter verschenken und wie
gesagt jeder karton ist individuell groß
weil einfach geschenke mit drin sind die
eben auch individuell sind das bedeutet
ich habe hier einen kalender voll
gepackt mit meinen eigenen artikel da
sind artikel drin zu backen also back
werkzeuge koch werkzeuge also es nicht
zu speziellen muss ich sagen weil ihr
nicht jede von euch torten backt aber
ich glaube dass jedes geschenk schon
sehr gut ist was man ganz gut brauchen
kann es gibt auch lebensmittel wird
dabei was du machen oder auf somit
verarbeiten wir haben auch
kosmetikartikel mit drin und auch
produkte die es noch gar nicht gibt bei
mir die arbeit demnächst erst online
kommen das heißt so eine art prix lauf
bekommt ihr dann im adventskalender und
was glaube ich ganz wichtig ist dass
keine produkte produkt größen drin sind
also diese kleinen test größen keine
proben sondern wirklich alles
vollwertige produkte eine handvoll
artikel gibt es auch von meinen partnern
also wo ich einfach was mit reingepackt
habe was ich jetzt nicht selbst
herstelle was ich aber extrem gut finde
und deswegen ist es wirklich glaube ich
ein adventskalender der schöne ist wir
werden denen jetzt auch demnächst
komplett verpacken das heißt er geht
jetzt im vorverkauf da ist auch etwas
günstiger als später zur adventszeit und
dann verpassen wir denn alleine mit
unserem team in sulz da wo eben unser
onlineshop ist dann nehmen wir natürlich
auch stories mit ohne inhalt verraten
und wenn euch das zeigen weil das doch
extrem viel arbeit ist das alles ist
einfach zu verpacken dass da nichts
fehlt es sind und auch gutschein kurz
mit dabei oder sogar gutscheine mit
warenwert das heißt eben kommt da auch
warum wertgutscheine und daher finde ich
das so ganz cool was ich heute machen
werde ihr dürft einen dieser kalender
gewinnen wir dürfen einfach einen
kommentar hinterlassen
ob ihr sehen möchtet dass ich heute
abend zum beispiel noch 23 türchen auf
mache schreibt gerne einfach eine szene
ich möchte sehen wie die zweite türchen
auf passt oder eben nein ich möchte mich
komplett überraschen lassen und unter
allen die heute jetzt kommentieren unter
diesem beitrag werde ich dann einfach
einen kalender verlosen wichtig ist nur
zu wissen der wird dann nicht direkt
diese woche oder nächste woche
verschickt sondern eben dann wären wir
die kalender verpackt haben das ist
ihnen wenigen wochen denn bis dahin
müssen wir noch ordentlich arbeiten also
ich hoffe dann gefällt euch wenn ihr
wollt dass ich ein zwei drei sachen
auspacke später ins paris des schreckens
konzern dann drück ich euch die daumen
der gewinner wird per los gezogen und
ich hoffe euch gefällt man kann